あっは
やっべぇ
七夕なのに
今起きた
こんにちは、はじめ社長です
七夕、皆さんどんなお願いごとをしましたでしょうか？
僕、願いというかちょっと悩みがありまして
あの、たぶんね皆さん気づいてないと思う！
一歩一歩深刻に僕は、
デブの道を行っています！
ゆうてそんなふとってはないんだけどね。
体はふとってはないんだけども、問題はお腹よ！
横から見てください
はい
キラン
わかります？わっ、わかっ、わかりますか？
パンッ、パンッ、パンッ
ちょっとブヨってね？
あの、ようやくね自分のからだの特徴がね、わかってきたよ。
基本的にからだは、こう、まだぜんぜん細いんですけど
お腹が！ペシッ
太ってきた
わかんない、もうなんかわかんないけどお腹のお肉が確実に、ちょっとずつついてきてるとおもってます。
もうだって、ほらもうビョーン
もうちょっとね、前までここスラッとしてたんだけど最近もう
ふくらんでるわけよ、こう
かがんだ時とかもう腹が、でりゅ、でりゅ
からだがもう割れないんだよね。腹がもう割れない。
あー　すごいなんかまどか☆マギカのキュゥべえみたい
まだ！まだもどれると俺は思ってる！
まだあの頃の腹に俺はもどれると思ってたんですけども、楽して！！
楽したいんすよ！人は楽したいんすよ
だから、楽にこうからだをもっとバキバキにできないかなと思ったときに、
衝撃的な商品に出会いました！こちら
さっき届いたんですけど、これですね！
金剛筋シャツ！　こわそうでしょ？
これすごいんすよ！
これ、何がすごいかといいますとなんかネットで見たんですけど
ネットの情報が正しければ、着るだけでからだがバキバキに割れます。
やばいっしょ　発売開始からわずか半年で１０万枚突破
２４時間トレーニングウェア
楽天市場ランキング第１位獲得！
着ながらボクサー肌へ。
ただの下着だとなめてるとあなたは衝撃を受けることになる。
着れば体感する金剛級の力！
たるんだからだを２４時間いじめぬく！
俺なんか宣伝の人みたい
もーそうそうこれを着たらねもうなんかねからだをすぐ引き締めるみたいなこと書いてあるんで
着てるだけで２４時間トレーニング祖てるような感覚があるらしいです。
かっこいいかっこいいってかいてあるけど痩せるのかな？
なんかなんかすごい
２週間でこれだけ変化しましたみたいな画像があって
けっこうかわってますね
２週間でこんなにかわる？？わかんない、でもネットの情報だからな
信じがたいなー
っていうところなでんすよ！
ネットの情報では２週間でからだがバキバキに進化した
かたわらでは、まったく効果がなかった！どっちが正しいかわからんやろ？
だから、僕がこの筋トレまったくしてないんで筋肉がほぼない
この状態のからだが金剛筋シャツをきることによってどこまで変化するのか
検証していきましょう
とりあえずどんなものかっていうのがまず見てみたいんすよねー
見た目からまずすごいっていう話を聞いた
うおー、えーー！！まってこれやばいじゃん
西松屋じゃん！サイズ的には
えっ、まってす、えっ、だってこんなのきたら死んじゃうよー
え、まってまって西松屋じゃん完全に
僕は今から赤ちゃんが着るような西松屋の服をきて
からだをこう２４時間引き締められ続けて、からだがこう鍛えられるみたいなな原理だと思います。
うわーうわーうわ、ねえこれまじか
これきるの大変だな。
うわまってこれやばい。きるのしんどい
うお　あーやばいやばい　うーわー
くぅー
まって、女の人みたいになっちゃった
うーわ　これやばいぞ　うわまって　谷間だ
わぁこれすごいなぁ　やば　やばいやばいやばい
うわーやばいこれすごい！！うわーこれたぶんいけるわ
うわーすご　うわーなんかじんわり痛みがするぐらいちょっと引き締められてます
これ絶妙なラインだから
効果があるかわかんないですけど、なんかすごい指圧されてる感じはちゃんとあります。
こうやって普通のシャツきてもあんまばれないという利点があります。
はぁー
はい、というわけでたぶんだいたい２週間ぐらいかな
２週間ぐらいこれを着続けて
僕のからだの変化を見てみたいと思います。
ではまた、２週間後お楽しみに！
たくさん買っといてよかったー
エンディングテーマ